well imagine getting hundreds of dollars
in gift cards only to find out they've
already been spent it happened to one
young woman who posted her frustrations
on tick tock well then brian she called
the i-team our david charns got answers
about how this works and what you can do
the next time
you buy a gift card i am so frustrated i
have to share this though because it's
absolutely crazy amanda lindman's
frustration boiling over on tick-tock
all over a gift that's turned into a
headache
him giving me those cards just showed
that he was trying to support
my dream of wanting to open my shop her
boyfriend bought her four
100 dollar apple gift cards at a local
target
but when she went to use them to buy an
ipad the money was gone
to see that all of the money had been
taken we were
like our jaws both dropped she's not
alone a class action lawsuit filed in
federal court over a similar problem
according to court documents a
california woman says she bought a 50
apple gift card for her son at a walmart
but when he went to spend it
the money was gone it is a big
problem like everywhere rhonda mettler
investigates cases like this
with the better business bureau as soon
as a card is activated they've got that
information
and they can just go in and drain it dry
to have access to that number you have
to break a seal so you have to like
slide open the sticker seal it's unclear
right now how the numbers are being
stolen
the cards are activated at the register
and linman says a representative told
her the cards were used within
30 minutes of their purchase okay this
is a huge story time for literally
everyone as she waits for answers
lindman's videos are being watched
thousands of times and the comments are
rolling in
ultimately i just wanted to try to get
the story out and see
who else it was affecting and it's clear
that it's affecting a lot of
people a representative from target
telling the i-team once the card is
activated
only apple can help with a potential
refund apple responded to our inquiry
asking for the customer's information
they have not yet provided a further
response terms and conditions from apple
say neither it nor the store that sells
the card are responsible for quote
any lost or stolen gift cards or use
without your permission
linman says right now she just wants
that ipad in either way
her boyfriend is out 400 bucks someone
else spent
i'm david charns 8 news now david thank
you the better business bureau says
you can protect yourself by checking the
packaging on the card
see if it's been tampered with also
treat the card like cash
and if there's a way to register it do
it we've posted more resources online
at eight newsnow dot com